Speaker 1: Let's go back to the phones, by
which I mean our discord voice server, which
you can find at David Pakman dot com slash
discord, there are so many people hoping to
get on.
Let's talk to some of them.
Why don't we go to Ryan from Dallas, Texas.
Ryan, you're on the air.
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you fine.
Speaker 6: Hi there.
So, you know, I'm a I'm a young black man,
and, you know, I'm not I don't really consider
myself to be too liberal or conservative.
I kind of find myself in the middle.
And I don't really like to cry wolf for every
single issue with the minority, like to assess
it based on case by case basis.
But my question for you is, you know, Jim
Crow, only fifty six years ago and there were
there really wasn't anything significantly
done to try to uplift, you know, and compensate
the black community for those years of oppression.
Yes.
And my question to you is, what do you think
should have been done and at the time and
what do you think we could do now?
Speaker 1: Well, the problem at the time was
that, as we have very much learned, simply
changing the rules on paper to outlaw certain
types of discrimination.
It, number one, doesn't actually eliminate
the discrimination right away.
And number two, it doesn't actually set people
up on an even playing field.
I've used the monopoly analogy before.
If a new player enters a Monopoly game after
a few people have been playing for an hour
on paper, you can say everybody's playing
by the same rules.
But all the properties have been purchased
and the bank already has relationships with
the existing players, etc..
OK, that's the analogy.
So I think that was the missed opportunity
then.
Now, I don't know if you're getting towards
the idea of of reparations or not.
My thoughts on this and people people get
very angry with me.
Some people get angry with me when I say it.
But this is an issue I've looked into to a
significant degree.
I don't claim to be an expert on it.
I have not seen evidence that sort of throwing
money at people is actually going to solve
the issues that remain as vestiges of the
slavery and Jim Crow era.
Throwing money at people won't solve a lot
of the geographic structural issues that we
have in terms of neighborhoods and public
transit and a lot of other different things.
It won't, at least not in any direct way solve
some of the education inequalities that exist.
So I am open to the idea of a reparative process,
but I'm more interested in seeing how it can
go to structural change rather than necessarily
like tossing money at people.
Speaker 6: Right.
I completely agree.
I definitely think that there needs to be
a new basic standard for, you know, I mean,
simply simple stuff like apartments.
You know, a lot of these people are living
in these apartments that are just or I mean,
just horrid apartments.
I used to live in some terrible apartments,
rat infested when I was when I was little.
So.
And also schools, you know, they're so underfunded
and you have these schools in the suburbs
buying, you know, new stadiums.
So I'm completely on board with that.
Speaker 1: Now, let me ask you this.
You said that you're not super left or right.
What's an issue on which you consider yourself
a centrist?
Like, is there a social issue where you're
Speaker 6: For instance, you know, this bill
that came out about the Equality Act, you
know, I completely agree that there needs
to be some formal, you know, regulation on
not being discriminated because of your gender
identity and things like that.
But like, I don't agree with that.
You know, that they should be able to play
in the sport that they identify with.
I guess I guess in my opinion, that's being
neutral, but I don't know.
Speaker 1: Hold on.
Does that apply to all sports or only certain
sports?
Speaker 6: I honestly haven't thought about
it that much.
You know, I guess in my mind, I would initially
think about the more physically, you know,
where you know where where your physical stature
is more important and significant.
But I guess I guess maybe it's just a defense
mechanism because I want people to actually
listen to me versus just making assumptions
about me because, you know, I'm a young black
guy.
Speaker 1: So it almost sounds like, in a
sense, you are taking some of these positions
to posture as something other than a liberal.
Speaker 6: And maybe I maybe that could be
the case.
Yeah, I would think about that.
I definitely don't think that I'm I'm more
liberal than conservative for sure.
Speaker 1: You don't think so?
Or you are more liberal?
Speaker 6: No, no.
I am definitely more liberal than conservative.
Speaker 1: I see.
Yeah, that's coming through.
That's coming through.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right.
Take care.
We are hearing from people via discord at
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
The waiting lobby is the place to signal your
interest in getting on air with me.
Why don't we go next to let's go to Annette.
Annette, you are on the air.
Annette, that you can on mute and then we'll
be able to chat.
Annette, I
would love to speak to you, but I can't if
you mute yourself and I would give you just
this one last opportunity, of course, with
peace and love.
All right, no, Annette, that's really too
bad.
That's a shame